first you are a Republican who did not
support President Trump what was 2016
like for you tennis all politically
homeless 2016 was a hard election we did
have to in my view very flawed
candidates and I am a decision not to
vote for either candidate because I am a
Republican but Donald Trump is an option
was not tenable for me and so I largely
sat that one out and it's because of
what I observed through the campaign as
a former staffer to Ted Cruz as a CNN
political commentator and there were
certain lines that Donald Trump crossed
that I just feel made him in an
unacceptable candidate and on the other
side there was no reason for a
Republican to vote for the Democratic
presidential candidate and so what are
people like me gonna do yeah preaching
to the choir we're the lines that Donald
Trump crossed for you were they
political or were they personality were
they moral what what kind of line
although both I would say very early on
I was worried about his stance on
eminent domain of all things I mean we
wanted real back in the policy thing but
largely his attacks in the press very
early on his advocacy for torture that
was a real bright line when he said I
want to go after these people in spite
of suggesting that he would instruct
troops in the field to do obscene things
my brother served in Marine Corps that
to me it was a non-starter for a
commander-in-chief and then when he
started accusing people of the Cruz
campaign of just election crimes for no
reason without any evidence so those
were things like he is not fit to be
commander-in-chief and I even went so
far in writing in March of 2015 it
quote-unquote blacklist of politicians
who were endorsing him saying if you are
a professional Republican like me who
you know works in campaigns works in
Capitol Hill you should not work for
these people because their judgment is
flawed and they're giving credence to
this candidate and giving him
credibility that he does not deserve and
so at that point there was no going back
for me uh I believe I became a target
the Trump campaign because of that
stance but I don't take it back and I
think we're seeing some of that play out
and while Donald Trump does have some
clear wins tax bills great
we might get some progress in North
Korea crossing my fingers hope we're all
praying for him on that but the constant
attacks on civility decency the chaos
which is unnecessary he could be a great
president if he would just cut out the
nonsense but you get what you get well
let's before we talk about what's in the
book let's talk about how you wrote it
because I was struck by how vivid some
of your memories from covering the
campaign were I covered the campaign
it's like a whirlwind to me I mean down
to you arrived in st. Louis off the
plane your hair still went from the swim
you took were you taking notes over the
course of the campaign with writing a
book in minds no but there were certain
flash points like the scene that I
recall when I was flown to st. Louis for
the debate the last moment was so vivid
because that was the Access Hollywood
weekend right and I just remember every
moment of that because it seemed like
Dom we may lose a presidential candidate
and probably for good reason and then
Donald Trump brought out Bill Clinton's
accusers I mean all of this was so
shocking right wild and recounting it
part of the reason I recount all this is
because it's going to happen again
like there's this fantasy among people
that Donald Trump is suddenly going to
wake up and be presidential
how many times have we heard that and
can people keep saying well can you
believe what he just said I've been
hearing that since 2015
he's not going to change but people who
need to take him on or have to live in
this media environment have to adapt
well I think yeah I in reading this I
was transported back no it was it was
astonishing because I lived it yeah but
for someone who who who didn't you you
really feel like you're right in there
so let's get into it first explain what
gas lighting is for someone who might
not know but about the book is I have
explained what gas lighting is but the
tub subtitle why we love it when Trump
lies nobody can test any lies so
we all agree on that but gaslighting the
way I explain it to people imagine if
someone approached you on the street
it's a beautiful day and said I see what
color is the sky you look up it's blue
they say no it's green you look up again
no it's blue and then they parade a
field of experts with weird scientific
studies from the internet and screaming
eagle comm saying no the sky is green
and then there CNN debate panels to
debate what color the sky is and so you
sort of have two choices when this goes
on it grates on you you either say okay
they have a viewpoint they have a lot of
economic anxiety maybe they see the sky
is green or you go crazy and we start
saying no you idiots the sky is blue and
then they say oh look at that hysterical
woman right sounds familiar
so that's like pretty much the method to
Trump's madness here so talk about the
steps because I thought one of the most
fascinating things was you really
identify the steps from takes every
single time they're always the same walk
me through them starting with one he
stakes out territory no one else would
occupy give me an example that the best
way to understand the method to Trump's
gaslighting is to revisit his birtherism
campaign against Barack Obama staking
out a politically toxic narrative is
something Trump always does
it makes him unique and makes him stand
out something no one else would say and
it's always something that scho is kind
of floating out there he doesn't come up
with it on his own when Donald Trump
started doing the birtherism stuff it
was during a Barack Obama's second term
like this was already over after you
know John McCain shouted somebody down
for calling him a Muslim
I'll that actually came out in 2008 and
we had the whole like Orly Taitz
you know doing the lawsuits but then
Donald Trump started getting into it
around 2011 saying um you know anything
about this so that's him like getting
out there pushing it out there and it
was fruitful he realized there were a
lot of Republican base voters who were
upset that candidates like John McCain
and Mitt Romney wouldn't use this right
and so that's him kind of saying yeah I
got you I got you
and then so that's step one he's I'm
gonna do
step two once you see this you're not
gonna be able to unsee it I call it
advance and deny mm-hmm and so he starts
doing interviews saying well did you
read this there might be something to
that I'm not saying but other people are
saying and so this is him pushing it out
there but not taking responsibility for
it and he could be in this step for a
long time it gets him a lot of
interviews and then everyone does the
headlines is Donald Trump a birther
right then we all get to debate it and
he at that point he has started to
control the media environment and then
suspense
he creates suspense all the time I have
investigators going to Hawaii there's a
report coming soon and even at that
stuff he suggested there was a videotape
coming and so that generates more media
interest well let's see what he has to
say let's see if something comes up
guess what spoiler it never comes out
comes out right and then he selects a
detractor yeah attack yes he finds
someone at this point people start to
come out and say we think Donald Trump
is lying well I'm not lying other people
other people are just talking about this
I'm just looking into it and so he
starts to Zona and anybody that pops up
loser crazy hack and so if you can find
a target to start scapegoating and have
it us-versus-them fight that's when it
really creates that dynamic and then
finally he declares victory yes it like
he did with the press conference at the
Trump Hotel in DC everyone come in I'm
gonna have a major announcement you can
also look at my beautiful grand new
hotel if you want and he essentially
said yeah Barack Obama's a citizen I
cleared it up I'm the winner but Hillary
Clinton started it uh-huh I finished it
victory so you asked early on in the
book is this what Republicans waited
four years in the political wilderness
for to babysit Trump's Twitter account
and compete in a never-ending tournament
of mental gymnastics to defend Trump
from one self manufactured crisis to the
next I sense your frustration again I
mean take me back to 2012 right the
autopsy comes out Republican Republicans
like you and I
start doing the hard work of getting us
back getting us back in favor among
different kinds of voters minorities
women Millennials and then all of a
sudden Trump comes along yeah and sort
of gaslights
right how all of that it's up in smoke
gone isn't gone forever the potential
it's gonna be a long road I mean it is
Trump's party now truly you and I would
not defend this stuff but there is a
never-ending cast of characters who will
jump up to defend Trump and I get in
that the book there's always incentives
for people to go along with the lie
especially Republicans because there's
power and influence and opportunity
available I mean I consider myself a
never Trump Republican I'm never gonna
work for them I'm never gonna vote for
them there's no glory and never trumpism
people say oh manda you got a book yeah
I did I've also lost out an opportunity
as a Republican in good standing with a
good work history of ever working in the
ministration there's lots of costs
involved and so people say well why do
people go along with it well all the
upside is available to go along with her
find a way to burrow in the
administration there's people there who
are doing good work but if you take a
position like I do that's over well I
want to talk about that he walked me
right into the next question you talked
about people who decided to work for
Trump during the campaign I want to read
how you describe them most of his media
surrogates were tea party misfits and
other striving activists who would never
survive the vetting of any professional
GOP campaign they didn't have anything
to lose in supporting Trump and neither
did Trump in accepting their support
people made fun of people who ended up
going on TV who live for President Trump
a candidate Trump or defend him contort
themselves to defend the latest crazy
thing that he said they were mocked why
did they do it why did they withstand
that embarrassment the scrutiny you talk
about a lack of shame yeah but what was
in it for them other than 15 minutes
on camera I mean it was an opportunity
they never would have gotten before I
mean I didn't write that paragraph to be
mean it's because I knew the people who
were going aboard and working for Trump
and I had worked for campaigns I had
worked in offices they would not have
passed by betting and so the lack of
shamelessness isn't like why did that
happen it's a qualification to work for
Donald Trump and it's paid off in the
many ways right like there's
opportunities available and pac-world
Fox News presents endless opportunities
and so why do people do it if you can
get past the lack of shame it's easy but
but you know as well as I do that plenty
of people went into that White House
left with not a lot of credibility right
so is it short term short term fame and
glory long term I think the 95 is white
a little bit in the White House because
I do give people some credit for
believing they need good people there to
try to help Trump which is short-sighted
I mean that never works out but I know
people who have gone in who fully
recognize his flaws I draw a distinction
between people who actively live for him
before the public and someone who may
want to go work in the State Department
or the FCC or something like that to me
that's a big difference like you can go
serve your country but once the reline
for me for working for any politician
once they have you live for them you
have to go and my experiences that was
watching mark Sanford many years ago
when he was governor of South Carolina
and he made his staff live for him
saying he wasn't having affair with his
wife he's hiking on the Appalachian
Trail well lo and behold he's out of the
country having an affair he made his
staff why you got to go and we see her
at Sarah Huckabee Sanders actively lying
being caught in the lies is that not the
job of the press no it shouldn't be
Jerry know when your boss marches you
out to tell falsehoods that's not spin
that's not giving the press your side of
the story that's using taxpayer
resources and the might and force of the
US government to lie and that is wrong
do you think anyone could do that job
though without having to lie maybe for a
week or two honestly you would have to I
in that position and this is why I
admire what Jeff Sessions is doing right
now make them fire you you can go in
there you're not there to serve the
president you were there to serve the
country and once he makes you choose you
make him fire you I want to talk about
megyn kelly okay yes talk about how
Trump took her down yes and why you say
it was his first major effort in his war
against the media mm-hmm megyn kelly got
gas-lit to pieces and she did a good job
withstanding the fire but if you go back
she was the first one to really ask him
hard questions about his treatment of
women in that first Republican debate
when he she listed off the things that
he had said and he essentially called
her crazy and then he went on a campaign
against her and it wasn't even I don't
think it was even about her it was about
gaining control over Fox News and taking
her out making Roger Ailes pick sides
going after in their Twitter account we
called her hysterical compared her to a
wild animal that was bleeding out
wherever and then said he didn't mean it
he didn't say it and Roger Ailes
initially did take sides he defended
megyn kelly and asked for an apology of
course they would never come never
apologized do you think before that
moment Fox was undecided about the
direction it would go in terms of
supporting Donald Trump do you think
it's because Donald Trump made Roger
Ailes pick sides from my experience the
campaign I think they favored marco
rubio right actually but Donald Trump
went in and went against their rising
you know a night rising star one of
their top anchors franchise yeah yeah
completely and he won that fight didn't
he she's no longer there he has no one
that will ask him a tough question like
that at Fox News again do you think it's
because of that moment that's how it
started absolutely because he attacked a
franchise mm-hmm anchor personality and
even though the network tried to stand
behind megyn kelly maybe the viewers
works
supported that's right this is a part of
the guest lady where he sort of knows
there's a problem out there because
there I mean I know this there's a lot
of conservative viewers who always
thought megyn kelly she's not really one
of us she tries to play I've heard this
many times because she wasn't as
dogmatic as a Bill O'Reilly or Sean
Hannity she did try to be more fair and
not play the pure political game all the
time mm-hmm and who's in her spot now
right so what do you what do you make of
the defense of from at FoxNews a place
you and I have worked is stunning to
watch as Sean Hannity in particular I've
written some very tough pieces about him
for Politico among other places and what
is amazing to me is that all through the
Obama years conservative media was like
how dear the media be lapdogs for the
administration I mean have you watched
that show lately I mean it's at times I
wonder if we have a state-run media or a
media run State mm hmm hmm yeah that's a
that's a become a popular refrain yeah
for Fox News because at least for the
opinion anchors right to be very and
curious about this presidency and what's
happening open mic every morning right
to talk to three people largely
unchallenged I mean even when he gets
into rough territory they say oh okay
president don't you gotta go do
something now cut it off I mean it's
really incredible to watch is is part of
the the gaslighting effect that from
only goes to friendly media outlets and
will not do tough interviews that part
of his it's part of it but the bigger
thing to me the gas lighting isn't only
about Trump it's about the people who
enable it it's the fact that he can call
in and be so completely unchallenged the
fact that people Sean Hannity will get
on the phone with him every night and
essentially work out a script for the
next day I mean they're they're lit too
they're going along with it big time
they don't see they the sky is green in
Trump's eyes let's talk about my least
favorite term of all time fake
how did Trump come to take that up as a
campaign write drop essentially yeah cuz
he didn't invent it nope but how many
how many stumble on it how did he make
it so successful yeah an idea well and
that this is another one of those things
that was floating around a lot of
academic scholarly types were starting
to talk about fake news in the way that
there actually was fake news on the
internet even since and I don't know
what caused it to start happening but
after 2013 there was all kinds of fake
conservative websites popping up I mean
this is really before Donald Trump was
getting into it I noticed it from Ted
Cruz's office we would get confronted
with all the time where people would
essentially take a screenshot of Ted
Cruz and write a fake quote with him
like about slavery or something crazy
that was clearly wrong yeah but people
would make it look like he said it in an
appearance at Fox News and they were
they were essentially hoaxes completely
designed yeah well people and I would
have to spend hours in the press shop
explaining to people no this didn't
happen and this would drive me crazy
well here's what he said what'd he have
to say and then I'd have to eat up three
or four hours explaining he never said
that right and so fake news was
happening but Donald Trump co-opted it
to mean legitimate mainstream news he
didn't alike and so then we had this
whole fight we're still having this
fight what is fake news what is not he
grabbed ahold of that term where there
is fake news on the internet which at
this point I think largely benefits
Trump more than anybody if you look at
the studies from what was put out on
Facebook even from you know Russia TV
that was pure Russian propaganda that
was made up to benefit Trump so yeah
there is a fake news problem but it
helps Trump mm-hmm much more than it
hurts him and how dangerous is it in an
atmosphere where fake news is being
bandied about by Trump yeah at every
turn when we in the media do get it
wrong right that's those unforced errors
yeah really just feed right into his
hands right absolutely and I've my
belief is that you know it's okay to be
called out Trump
challenges the media
be better yeah the media had a Probab
which I am a part of not being fair to
conservatives it still has a problem
with that even if you look at what
happened with this Roseann thing and
what people like Samantha B are seeing
about Ivanka Trump and what keith
olbermann is saying on a non-stop basis
that doesn't get nearly the same
attention right and so there still is a
balancing that needs to happen and I
wish that Trump would force people to
rethink that balance a little bit more
rather than get spun up about whether
they're fake news or not do you think I
mean the polling does suggest that his
fake news attack on the media is working
yeah people are trusting the media less
and less how does the media combat that
Bisaya getting better right yeah I don't
think you can I mean and one hand I say
make fun of Trump surrogates you say
this he won you do have to deal with the
fact that he has a bully pulpit no one's
gonna stop him from saying what he wants
to say right we're forced to live in
this environment and so we do have to do
better but part of this is largely
because the media does focus on things
like the Russia investigation which
Trump is convincing people are is not
legitimate right and so bear down report
the facts it is a story stick to the
story and the best way that the media
cannot get caught up in this Trump spin
cycle I think is to retake their power
back but being so reactive to every
chomp tweet there was a time when you
just did your own stories you know call
him for comment he's not the story all
the time he is the president but he
doesn't have to be the story every day
unless you want him to be here's
something I never thought I'd say in
2018 let's talk about white nationalism
yep so you say one of the biggest cons
that from polled since becoming
president was this longtime flirtation
with white nationalists talk about how
that relationship began yeah this is
that we thought play out in the both
sides argument after charlottesville but
had been going on a long time before
that
when we talk about the fake news and the
fake media you can't do that without
discussing the troll factor which really
came to a head this election and a lot
of it without a doubt was white
nationalistic controls and it first
really began to pop up when they started
going after Jewish reporters it was
brutal
when was this before the campaign or
during the campaign and those are the
troll army that largely came out in full
support of Trump and so when you watch
what they did to a writer like Ben
Shapiro
or Jonathan Wiseman at The Wall Street
Journal I mean it was not only vicious
but you couldn't track it it was so much
and I kind of lay out in the book like
once a horde of trolls feel comfortable
telling people to get in the oven in
public in public yeah with their names
right website yep I mean it's all out
there
mmm they'll say anything for Trump right
and they did mm-hmm
do you think because when I was when I
was covering some of those moments I
thought gosh someone must have told
candidate Trump you need these people to
win and so wink and nod at them
occasionally
yeah do you think it's that worse he
sympathizes with them or do you think he
used them I think it's more the latter I
think Donald Trump is a manipulator in
anything that can help him he will use
if there is any weapon on the field no
matter how vile he's not gonna turn it
down and that's why I think Donald Trump
jr. was retweeting these people and you
that's why you get a comment like both
sides and there's always the thing is
Donald Trump a racist that comes up I
don't know for sure I know he engages in
racist behavior yeah and I am not sure
if he's just playing that which to me is
just as bad right is being a racist and
he wants people to think he is hmm you
talk about the origins of some of trumps
tactics and one of those stems from the
Lewinsky affair when the Clintons went
after Bill's accusers
what did Trump and everyone else learn
from that moment guess lighting works
I feel like Monica Lewinsky needs a
retelling I do and she's been popping up
a little bit more she got called a bimbo
a narcissist a liar defending what she
did what Bill Clinton did but to deny
the fact that he wasn't engaging in a
romance with her he invited her into the
Oval Office and somehow she made out he
gave her gifts and somehow she's the one
that got to got sent off for years and
years and he got to keep being president
I'm not sure you should have been
impeached Schobert really but I do know
that they gas lit the heck out of that
woman and so after that point people
learned you can get away with that and
that is a big part of how Donald Trump
got away with the access hollywood tape
he brought Bill Clinton's accusers to
him essentially hid behind these women
at the debate is reminding everybody
Bill's worse he did this kind of stuff
and you can get away with lying about it
and I'm not sure Bill Clinton totally
got away with lying it because it wasn't
impeached but it did work taught for how
long did Monica Lewinsky have to stay in
hiding over something that happened that
was true that he eventually admitted
yeah yeah and and more than the lying
what I took away from that moment was
how viciously liberals and liberal women
feminists like Gloria Steinem you talk
about this in the book turned their
targets on these women accusers which is
so startling to remember especially in
this me too yeah era but before me too
when Trump was discrediting his multiple
accusers during the campaign it really
did hearken back to that and Bill
Clinton got away with it sort of drunk
yeah and now you see Trump's supporters
making the same arguments that the
feminists did to cover up for Bill
Clinton saying well we want to get the
policy we want we want to you know do X
Y & Z this just isn't high on the
priority list so Trump is president now
another couple years probably yeah you
you talk about how the gas lighting is
different yeah but still happening yeah
and we're approaching midterms mm-hmm
another campaign season and obviously
2020 do you see it ramping up do you see
it evolving into something else I think
it could go off the change what one note
on why the gas lighting is a little bit
different than president Clea Donald
Trump gas lights as an offensive
mechanism a lot of people kind of do
these gas lighting things when they're
caught lying saying oh that person is
crazy don't pay attention to them Donald
Trump just like actively picks a target
and starts making up lies preemptively
preemptively offensively for fun and so
you've got the thing that I pretty sure
is gonna pop back up where he thinks
that there was millions of people that
voted illegally in the 2016 election at
that point he's really setting up a
rigged narrative for his correction law
right but he can still use that in 2018
he can still use that in 2020 and he is
yes what we've seen him starting to say
about the Muller investigation meddling
uh-huh in the 2018 in terms reminds me
of what he said about the rigged
election really yeah and I also has the
benefit of politicizing the report
whenever it comes out
I actually think because he used that
reg narrative during the election and
that prevented the FBI from making
statements about the investigation to
the Chama campaign during the election
so this stuff does work and it may
actually prevent a report from coming
out before 2019 but what I am most
worried about going into 2018 but more
so 2020 is that he is going to gin up
some wild and crazy things that may be
international what's to prevent him from
inventing a terrorist threat that
doesn't exist a market threat that does
not exist I mean I think we really if
you don't get it by now
the filter is off I mean during the
campaign there was this incident with
Michelle fields where Corey Lewandowski
pulled her down he suggested to a
reporter that she might have been a
terrorist and have a little bomb in her
hand
there's nothing stopping him from taking
wild statements like that in lighting it
up on a much larger level and I think
everyone needs to brace themselves for
that I know you joked a minute ago about
front gaslighting for fun yeah
preemptively his supporters love it they
do good time it is entertaining for them
and it obviously keeps all of us very
busy uh-huh but do you think there's
something more to it we're sewing this
kind of chaos and confusion and
frustration and madness mm-hmm
actually helps to sow distrust in all of
these democratic institutions the Free
Press the intelligence community law
enforcement so that he is really the
only person that can be trusted
absolutely he is not a madman he's a
manipulator he's playing everyone and
when he is in control of all of these
situations I mean he's doing all this
the chaos is control and the only way to
mitigate it because you're not gonna
stop it he's a president he's gonna keep
doing it is that people really have to
grab their bearings and not let him
create that chaos over them in the news
media
take back your programs a little bit I
tell people who are just sucked into it
and they say how I feel like I'm being
gassed lit all the time I say delete
Twitter off your phone sometimes it's
always gonna be there trust me you can
come back you can take a weekend off
Twitter I do it occasionally and when
you dip back into it you'll see it's all
the same so they're all the same we keep
falling for the same things again and
again and again so alternative facts to
something that came up through President
after Trump became president on around
the Trump tweet early on that Obama had
wiretapped had tapped his phone that's
from tower yeah that was sort of the
origin of alternative facts we're
hearing a similar claim now where he's
accusing the FBI of having spied on him
while a candidate some of this feels
very rinse and repeat
yes it absolutely is the Russian
investigation you gotta remember he's
been going after the FBI since
essentially his first day in office when
he had tweets about what are we living
and Nazi Germany this isn't a new thing
he knew something was happening and I
think as soon as he got in the office he
decided I'm gonna start going after the
FBI and then you see him saying oh I
fired after James Comey in that
interview with Lester Holt
well I fired him because of Russia but
there's nothing to it that is such a
classic advance and deny statement I
fired him because of Russia advance that
but deny it because there's nothing to
it and so he's been on this for a long
time I do think this one is a little bit
different because its defensive
gaslighting he is subject to whatever
the FBI puts out whatever investigator
Muller puts out so he is in a defensive
position on this which does make his
posture different but it doesn't make
his tactics different mmm talk about
Trump and Nixon since the whole Russia
investigation started people have
brought up Watergate which there are
comparisons there he's brought it up
which is crazy to me opinions like they
say this is the biggest witch-hunt since
Watergate and I'm like in Watergate it
was the president right does anybody
read Nixon was not the hero in that
story right but what is fascinating to
me is that the same things that will
have led Trump down a bad path led Nixon
down a bad path and that is hostility
towards the press and paranoia about
government leaks Watergate started when
Nixon had his men start breaking into
offices to find who was leaking the
Pentagon Papers which is kind of crazy
because that wasn't even on his watch
but he was upset about it and then once
they breached that they started breaking
in they broke into Watergate and that
actually was the third break-in because
he broke into Watergate twice they kept
they got away with it
but what's fascinating is that how many
people went along with it when the
similarities between Nixon and Trump and
how they can inspire people to go along
with things out of loyalty
really made an impression on me and in
part is because we've traveled in some
of the same circles but when I used to
work for a publication called human
events and at one point they sent me to
go do an interview with G chord and
Liddy mm-hmm
who I just knew as a talk radio host the
rabbit time I was like 23 year old like
sure right okay refresher he was one of
the people who broke in to Watergate he
suggested all kinds of crimes to the
Nixon team including killing a
journalist breaking into the DNC
kidnapping people I mean he's a felon
but somehow years later he's not like
some conservative hero that they send
little 23 year old journalists in
Capitol Hill to go do interviews with
hmm which is just I mean I was I
I was ignorant I fully admit that but
now realizing like okay gee Gordon
Liddy's now that you see in the Trump
administration by Bleich Carter page has
a little bit of a G gordon liddy vibe
like he'll go down with that [ __ ] right
and so it's just I think we should
reflect on the history of that to see
how far people will go because they'll
go pretty darn far in the name of
loyalty to a commander-in-chief mm-hmm
how do you see the Russia investigation
playing out if you had to predict if I
have to predict I think there's gonna be
a pretty devastating report and Moeller
ends up throwing it into the hands of
Congress will the house may be moved to
impeach Trump sure yes in a democratic
house but would the Senate convict him I
don't I don't think so and you have to
remember that Nixon resigned once they
move the impeachment papers out of the
Judiciary Committee in the house in
shame Donald Trump has no shame he will
absolutely dare Congress to impeach and
convict him in in that kind of
brinksmanship I think Donald Trump wins
that fight at this so I thought why I
love there's a you know dead Russians
discovered in the White House or
something really definitely right live
boy dead girl do you think that's why
from lawyer Rudy Giuliani is now pushing
Muller to end this by September in
case democrats take control of either
the house or this yeah
perhaps you're clearly playing the
political game they're not donald rudy
giuliani may be a lawyer but he's not
playing a lawyer surrogate
yeah and that's because they know this
is going to end up as a political fight
and so I don't think anyone's even
playing the legal game hmm so let's talk
about um how gaslighting can't be
stopped it's really depressed I know but
many people you make I mean you make the
good argument and you tell the hard
truth um I want to read a sort of long
longer passage because you describe our
relationship with Trump and I think a
very vivid way so you say typically
gaslighting is a type of manipulation
that takes place in one-on-one romantic
relationships think of a cheating
boyfriend who calls his girlfriend a
psycho when she becomes suspicious about
his late-night text messages from other
women or the woman who convinces her
husband that the leaky faucet
broken-down car an inability to live out
her dream lifestyle of the rich and
famous is all his fault in the worst
cases it becomes a debilitating form of
mental abuse victims find themselves
forced to defend themselves from how
landish accusations trapped in
unwinnable circular arguments and
apologizing for circumstances they have
no control over victims live in a
constant state of uncertainty and lose
confidence in their ability to react to
events they become dependent on their
gas lighters and unwilling to object to
their statements and actions a
psychologist would advise these victims
to terminate the toxic relationship or
if it involves a family member limit
contact unfortunately none of us have
this choice when it comes to Donald
Trump he's the president we're stuck yep
so what do we do I get this question all
the time and I have to tell people that
he has to be confronted but there's no
assurance of victory you have to get an
arena with him and because you know does
that mean we work in the media
environment there's a lot of people say
well why don't we just not go on these
programs I'm like you do that and you
see the entire media landscape - Trump
he
in that environment and so you have to
get into it and you're gonna get roughed
up
I got roughed up during the election oh
I will I would by way of the National
Enquirer I was suggested to be having an
affair with my former boss Ted Cruz
right in a trump supporter confronted me
on the air about it both campaigns had
issue statements about it I had to go
clear it up with my employer at CNN and
a live TV interview it never happened
right but I got trapped into this
alternate reality but that's the cost
there's no way I can tell someone if you
want to do this kind of work here's how
you're going to win and you're gonna
come out smelling like roses because he
fights dirty and the trick is he's going
to fight dirty and you have to hit him
back clean because otherwise you get
slung into the mud and I think people
should look at how James Comey was
treated when he did his media tour
uh-huh
Donald Trump went after him and so he
wanted to obviously go out and tell his
side of the story and I think in a
commendable way but the debate didn't
even become about facts it was well
isn't he sanctimonious mm-hmm what does
he think he is go in and do that media
tour people are gonna come at you and he
just gritted his teeth and said I'm
going to do this which was the right
thing to do
and I haven't told people that an
unlikely person Michael a vanetti is a
model for this he has I'm not defending
his client I don't like her line of work
but he is succeeding against Donald
Trump in the media world because one he
has his own story to tell he's not
reacting to Trump he says my client has
her truth Donald Trump and his people
didn't want her to talk about it it came
out in the media they denied it happen
she wants to write to her story and so
yeah is it salacious it's about sex yes
but it's about truth or not and he could
just quietly file his papers but he is
making himself available showing that he
has commander the facts and he's gonna
mess up along the way without a doubt
but he's not backing down and so I think
people need to at least look at him as a
model
and saying okay if you're gonna confront
Trump don't be reacted to him have your
own story to tell and you absolutely
cannot see the media space because that
is the environment where Trump lives you
can't beat him if you don't meet him on
the field and people tell me and others
in the media all the time well why do
you what do you have to cover everything
and and you know you you talked about
that as well you don't have to make him
the story every time but the flip side
of that right is that this is truly
remarkable mm-hmm and what he's doing is
not normal what he's doing should be
discussed right and so how do you find
that happy medium between not making him
the story every time but also getting
into the media space not seating it to
him and taking him on you know when you
can I think part of it is what Trump
says is not always the story what he's
doing I keep coming in mind about the
border crisis about you know people
being separated from families and it
keeps getting back into a debate about
you know what he says about ms-13 which
is of course newsworthy but that's the
comment on the underlying story which is
the immigration crisis the policy the
policy the fact that children have been
separated from their families there's
been horrible things going out there for
many many years but it's easier and this
is why the media goes along with it so
much it's so easy to just cover the
comments mm-hmm and so we have to dig a
little deeper and actually do find the
stories that people care about yeah but
it is I mean it's like an addiction it's
like that Trump Twitter keep giving it
to me one and it does give you going
yeah it's hard yeah exactly because it's
very clear Trump prefers the politics to
the policy absolutely there's always a
big sort of theatrical media moment
around something he wants to do like
withdraw from the Iran deal or the Paris
Accord or have a meeting with Kim
jong-un right yeah but there's little
thought to the policy behind it that's
gonna come next what what happens next
oh we got here I mean even the thing
with the Paris Accord new people are
really upset he got out of it well can
we spend five minutes about how we got
into it right
Barack Obama didn't go to
I mean why do you expect the next
president won't undo it as easily as it
was done and so that would be helpful
but I do think this gets into the
conversation a little bit about media
bias right would we rather cover the
fact that Trump is just ripping it up
rather than cover why it was bad we got
into this possibly would we rather cover
what Trump says about people at the
border rather than the crisis that's
been going on for quite some time I
think that's part of it yeah so some of
the things you say that other people can
do outside of the media yeah to deal
with gaslighting you say letting go of
the outrage yeah let go let go and let
God yes you can't keep getting yourself
worked up although I'm political junkie
but you kind of have to say okay here's
what matters here's what doesn't and
when you're just constantly posting on
Facebook and check you Twitter and going
to your favorite blogs I mean is that
really how you want to be spending your
time and it does matter it is important
I think people some people would say yes
yes how people this is a long game yeah
and so it's just kind of like saying am
i getting sucked into this because I
want to because this is healthy for me
because it makes me happy or if you want
to do politics should you get off the
dang computer and phone and go meet with
some people in your community you also
say add substance to your media diet
yeah
what do you mean by that it's social
media it's a big role it's so easy just
to scroll and scroll and scroll in the
biggest problem I'm sure I mean you know
this as a writer people read the
headline not the story I'm guilty of it
we're all guilty of it and read the
story before you push it out because you
have to take some responsibility for
what you are pushing out there it's hard
because people really do in today's
tribal America they really do just want
to be reaffirmed yeah in their own
beliefs and I get that it feels good
totally so how do you convince a fox
news viewer to watch MSNBC how do you
think that's gonna
how do you convince a New York Times
reader mm-hmm to you know pick up a copy
of the Daily Caller or the daily wire
you know I mean how do you how do you
convince people to leave their bubbles I
don't think that's even viable yeah at
this point but I think people need to
just look a little more deeply at the
stuff they're consuming I mean the
Internet is a great tool but the lack of
standards and I do think it's going to
change a little bit because we've seen
you can I mean obviously you can write
anything on there but there is a clear
difference between a now what that does
have accountability and that's what I
think is the big distinction about
adding media substance your diet are you
getting your news from somewhere that
does have layers of accountability
editors copy editors is there a byline
that goes to a real person that you can
find and if you're going to websites
they have no accountability
that's just written by some avatar in
some made-up name you need to rethink it
a little bit or at least verify it from
somewhere else
I think the conspiracy theories feel too
good totally and that was funny you know
we could we could talk about Roseanne
and why she was compelled you know
sucked into this world the conspiracy
theories feel too good yeah
to want to ask the hard questions is
this real who is this person behind it
you know that's a hard drug to get off
of her yeah and I talk about the power
of conspiracy theories because I think a
lot of people say well why do people
fall for that doesn't matter no
conspiracy theories are very powerful
they are
um they play a huge role in American
politics and they have I mean even since
I started doing conservative media with
Hillary Clinton I mean how many people
have gotten the conversation about have
you seen the email about how many people
the Clintons have killed Vince Foster or
people ari Clinton where I killed as
many people or Hillary Clinton has you
know Parkinson's I mean you could go on
and on it yeah and so and I spent some
time talking about the conspiracy
theories related around Hillary Clinton
in the book because it didn't matter
right I think that was a big reason why
she was a non-starter to many
república there have been the campaign
against her since the 1990s right and
she never tried to confront it she said
don't put it's a balcony right yeah it
actually is once you said that it
materialized well and people I think
make the mistake of dismissing
conspiracy theory and conspiracy
theorists as fringy yeah and really
those are the people you have to think
about yes and prepare for absolutely
because they're far more powerful than
just you know fringe no before it used
to be you get a chain letter and now
there's faux there people media
enterprises and the Alex Jones has
millions of followers yes and I got a
taste of this working in the cruise
office I think it was 2013 when we
started getting emails from very
concerned Texas about Jade helm which
were military exercises that had always
been happening but Alex Jones and some
people had said the government's
preparing to go to war against the
American people
sounds crazy but when people see the
tanks rolling through the highways
chemtrails
yeah and start getting worried about it
we would get calls and this isn't
happiness Cruz is just on a staff level
but we had to say like we know what this
is this is clearly stupid but we can't
tell people hey stupid idiot this is a
military thing that happens every year
because they're actually scared Wow and
so when people are coming from a place
of fear which played a huge role in this
election you do have to sympathize a
little bit and take the time to explain
what's going on rather than just saying
you're stupid because that just drives
them further in the bunker and that
happens a lot in 2016 yeah for sure
early on you talk about how every time
something crazy happens we think well
this is this is it this is gonna do me
and that's so dangerous because of
course nothing's gonna do him in and and
and falling for that every time is just
a recipe for madness like I need to
write another book titled no one is
going to save you from chunk Hillary
Clinton is not going to around Ted Cruz
isn't gonna do the convention that
didn't work Hillary Clinton is not gonna
do it robert muller probably isn't going
to do it his Twitter feed isn't going to
do it
you cannot owe me Daniels isn't gonna do
it Michael having it he's not gonna do
it you cannot escape the confrontation
right and people keep waiting for
someone else to save them
oh well the big thing I'm hearing now is
like well the Democrats are gonna retake
the house and they'll impeach him okay
you think the Democrats we haven't done
anything to confront Trump are suddenly
going to have a successful impeachment
strategy that's going to influence the
very likely Republican controlled Senate
you don't think I don't know so they may
try but okay so they impeach him in the
house he's still gonna be there that
doesn't save you people are at half
actually get in the game with him catch
him in the act when they start pushing
out these theories and people don't want
to do that if I learned anything from
the Republican primary is how
risk-adverse
people are and how uncomfortable people
are with confrontation especially if
they might lose something especially if
you might alienate a trump voter mm-hmm
that's not gonna happen and so if you
don't think it's worth it if you don't
think I mean it comes down to what our
country is going to be if you don't
think that's worth some short-term pain
then you've lost already couldn't come
down to something as simple as none of
these scandals are investigations but
people turn out to not like a trillion
dollar spending guess what they turn out
to not like some of the trade policies
that are being enacted you know people
like Joni Ernst and Chuck Grassley
worrying about some tariffs affecting
agriculture could it be as simple as
policies that people start not liking I
think his biggest threat among the
conservative base right now comes down
to two issues and that's a budget and
border if you look at the Tea Party
groups that really you know go in for
hands that supply him with a lot of the
you know just policy help that he gets
those are the two issues they want help
on they want the border wall or some
kind of enforcement at the border and
they want a better budget there's a
showdown coming in September Donald
Trump said he would never sign another
big omnibus spending bill like he did
earlier because
that made those groups angry like
legitimately like we may bolt on you if
you right you make us deal with a lot of
crap yep but if you're not gonna deliver
on these two policy items what's in it
anymore and so there's a confrontation
coming on the budget this fall and that
will have an impact and whether the base
is motivated or decides you know what
this guy is a lot of trouble I don't
think I can do it anymore and on the
border it was such an important issue
for Donald Trump running he hasn't
gotten his wall no he hasn't gotten his
ticket the way he just needs a couple
miles here he won't hear saying now he
will not sign anything that doesn't have
a wall an actual wall yeah he said and
increased border funding do you believe
him no I can't believe anything he says
but the base wants to truly believe that
and that might be something they may
actually hold him accountable for well
and I've always thought the base is is
likely in for some disappointment not
just because of Trump when it comes to
immigration but because it is
politically profitable for both
Democrats and Republicans to keep
immigration broken yeah and so solving
it means you can't run on it and you
can't fundraise off of it do you think
Trump is likely to transcend these long
years long
you know battlegrounds on immigration
between Republicans and Democrats who
really thrive when it is broken not
unless which he's been doing he can
convince the Democrats he's convinced
the base that the Democrats are the
boogeyman and they'll be worse and they
love ms-13 like he said about Nancy
Pelosi right but the frustration I mean
I came to Washington in 2005 immigration
was central to the conservative base at
that point it's been ripping the party
apart for ten years plus if he can't
deliver something tangible on that I
really do think that will be depressing
and another huge budget bill will be
depressing in a way that depresses
turnout and so will they ever walk away
from him no probably not because he's
their best hope in terms of getting what
they want it's not like that
Macross are ever gonna offer them
anything better or even like pretend to
understand where they're coming from on
these issues which you know that would
help guys and so I think the best you
know the worst outcome for him is that
they just get disillusioned but he'll
probably just try to make them scared
mm-hmm that's very powerful - do you
think you know you go back to Nixon you
talk about Bill Clinton and Nana and now
Trump do you think gaslighting becomes
the norm in politics or do you think we
were ejected after I mean I hope it's
rejected that's why I wrote the book
because I think once you identify these
steps he literally keeps doing the same
things over and over again right it
takes the power away but the temptation
to go do this now that the seal has been
broken you can get away with it for so
long will be very powerful and when I
look at the Democratic side I don't see
anyone trying to do anything better or
do anything worse it's just kind of this
mismatch of whatever in the celebrity
world I do think you see people seeing
that they can get away with this
gaslighting stuff and floating the
conspiracy theories I mean the
conspiracy theories are absolutely
normalized today you're not an outcast
if you say these things I mean you may
lose your job like Roseanne but
obviously they're talked about they're
spread and you can't stop that from
spreading well yeah and she didn't lose
her job because she believed it in pizza
gate she lost her job yeah that sort of
that should have been on me yeah that's
why yeah so it's my last question do you
think anyone from the left can beat
Donald Trump knowing how he campaigns
mm-hmm and how he felled 16 other people
on the right five other people on the
Left plays dirty is there anyone on the
left that can is prepared to go up
against him and then is there anyone on
the right the only person I see sort of
popping up in the left who I think who
has the right demeanor and I'm not
making you no policy endorsement or
anything like that but who has the
enthusiasm to do it I think it's Terry
McAuliffe he comes from a purple state
was governor of Virginia right has
experience in the Clinton White House
Clinton world
knows how this operates and he's got
some baggage to be sure yep
you think he could he has a personality
to go up against Trump a little bit I
mean just watching him over the years
he's he has the enthusiasm right I don't
know if he can braid together a
Democratic base and hold the
progressives and deal with all that
infighting right I don't know anybody
who can I mean they're gonna have a
clown show that is even bigger than the
Republican Club show I've been
predicting Oprah Oprah's the only one
pops up sometimes but in terms of just
like a traditional person with
experience and that's really kind of a
reach I don't know of anyone and neither
does anyone else because you kind of
have to be a crazy person to get into
this environment what's that look for
the crazy yeah what about it it's not
nothing's happening on the right mm-hmm
everybody keeps talking about whenever
pelvin gonna stand up and do something
like that died at the convention when
Ted Cruz stood up said vote your
conscience and got booed out of the hall
and even Republicans like you know our
friend on a Navaro said well why did he
even come he came to the convention
drank the wine and peed on the carpet
well I think that was better than
staying home like Jeb Bush and Jeff
Flake and John Kasich I still think the
party's worth fighting for but that is
what it would take to do this and I
don't see anyone with the nerve to do
that again I'm and a carpenter thank you
so much for joining me gas lighting
America and scrape okay